So again, in order to figure out how to evaluate each of these expressions, we
need to use our order of operations knowledge. We need to remember our PEMDAS.
For this first problem, negative 2 to the third power, we don't have any
parentheses, so that means we need to take the exponent into account before the
negative sign. So we have negative 1 times 2 to the third power, which is the
same as negative 1 times 8. So we get negative 8. The next problem has some
parethesis in it, so we need to deal with what's inside of those first. And
inside we have negative 2 squared. Just like in this first problem, you need to
do the exponent before the negative sign. So what's inside the parethesis here,
is negative 4, since we have negative 2 squared, which is negative 4. So this
equals 2 times negative 4 which is just negative 8 again. For the third problem,
we have an exponent outside of something that is inside of parentheses. SO we
know the negative sign is going to be part of the number that is taken to the
exponent, so the entire quantity negative 2 is squared. So this is equal to 2
times negative 2 times negative 2. Which is the same as 2 times positive 4,
which is positive 8. Again we have a negative sign inside the parenthesis. So
it's part of this number that is taken to the 3rd power. So negative 2 times
negative 2 times negative 2 is negative 8. Here the negative sign comes outside
the parenthesis. So you have negative 1 times positive 2 to the 3rd, 2 to the
3rd is 8. And negative 1 times 8 is negative 8. Our last two problems, both fall
into the neither category. 2 plus 2 squared, is just equal to 2 plus 4, which is
6. Which is not equal to either 8 or negative 8. And here we have negative 2
squared plus 2 squared. Since there's not a parenthesis around this negative 2,
we know that we need to square 2 before multiplying it by negative 1. So this is
actually equal to negative 4 plus 4, and that's equal to 0. Great job, I know
this a lot to do in 1 quiz, but I think that having to thi nk through all these
different options that are sort of similar to each other could be a really good
way to make sure you have your order of operations sense cemented. And if you
don't, not a big deal at all. Remember, just go back and practice a little bit
more.